Now that we've chosen
a coordinate system
for our runner going
along the road,
we now want to describe
the position function
of our coordinate
system with respect
to our choice of origin.
Now, the runner is
a non-rigid object.
Legs and arms are
moving back and forth.
So let's just imagine
that there is some fixed
point in the runner
at the center,
and let's give a vector.
So we're going to draw a
vector from above our origin
to that point, and this
is what we'll refer to
as our position function.
Now, remember, every point
here has an x-coordinate,
so we can now introduce
our position function,
which we'll call x of t, which
is the coordinate location
with respect to the origin.
This is a function that
will change in time.
And our position vector is r(t)
equals the position function
x(t).
Now, remember, this is a vector.
The position function
is just a quantity
that's describing the location
of this point with respect
to the origin, but
the unit vector
is how we describe this as a
vector, and so we write i hat.
Now, x(t) is what we call
the component of the position
vector.
Remember, a vector has a
component and a direction,
and the component is
the position function.
And that component
x(t) can be positive,
as you see in this
particular case.
x(t) can also be zero.
That's if you're
located at the origin.
And if our runner is on the
other side of the origin,
x(t) can be negative.
So the component of
the position vector
can be positive,
zero, or negative,
and the direction of
the position vector
is the sine of the
component times i hat.
If the component is negative,
then we have a negative i hat.
The position vector is pointing
backwards in the minus x
direction.
And if x(t) is positive,
positive i hat position
vector as shown in
this particular case
is in the positive
i hat direction.
So that's our first vector,
the position vector,
in one-dimensional motion.